[Music]
in sticky sex news oh yeah why I looked
at you guys did you know we have sex and
it seems like it's sticky
submitted by I'm man-bat
ma'am by it alright thanks maybe it's a
reference it's the opposite of Batman so
it's a bat that pretends that he's a
human so a vampire no like a bad he's
wearing like a human outfit how cute no
like you know Batman is Bruce Wayne
trying to be a bat that's pretty clear
what a Batman we're supposed to be on
the same page crazy alright a man was
charged after refusing to delete a sex
tape he made with a co-worker yeah what
the [ __ ] it's a very vanilla headline
right I mean like seductive this book
it's not like I haven't given you the
crazy part of it so here we go
this landscaper landscaper tight that's
a [ __ ] porno yeah you as Lansky's
this lady's yard all workers those two
Hispanic dudes are in each other wait
what there's women landscapers yeah
really feminist strikes as in
landscaping I've ever seen two Japanese
guys it is the worst of it
Mexican landscaper woman
it give me Rosarita
do they have licenses no I don't even
have citizenship this is a portal so
Roberts romance though it's Robert
Tom Lee O'Shea Korea's Korean MMO and
Ellie white oh oh that's really nice
that's the Vietnamese always but it's
it's the whole thing and II I'm fine Oh
M le Y one word Osam Lee oh that's
stupid I don't know it was Cambodian or
African I don't even know what that is
oh so he's 52 years old this is Robert
please be right still be Africa by the
way
South African ignore those who ignored
you mix up landscapers with just like a
maintenance gardener nobody here he made
a sex tape so this is what he did well
he was working in this house this
Connecticut home with his female
co-worker see yeah yeah I believe there
are he decided he told her to have a
secretary in the lunch sandwiches
schedule no they were both loading wood
into a trailer well they were loading
load my wood girl oh my wood
when Robert decided to take a tea break
right so he was like oh I'm gonna go use
the bathroom he's like oh it's really
hot in here so he was gone so after 20
minutes this 48 year old woman was like
hey where did he go so she went let me
suck his dick she went inside the home
and found him with the rose in his mouth
naked on the bed no found him with a
leaf blower found him naked masturbating
he was watching porn on a laptop being
standing there naked
maybe unload this wood so then she was
like what the hell are this is a portal
the portal yeah so then she was like
what are you doing and he was like oh I
need to take care of myself sexually
before returning to this porno this is
not really a [ __ ] porno line I need
to take care of myself
actually get a pizza guy come to also -
that line is very poor what are you
doing yeah you know very emotionless
nearly no what do you see in the
backseat obviously let me tell you the
rest so then she was like what that's
weird so she left he went back to
loading that's all she said
no I'm giving her these lines I don't
know what oh yeah well this is terrible
good for porno yes thank you yeah
actually wrote was that she shrugged him
off and returned to loading wood she's
like no he was like what about this wood
so then she returned back into the home
a short time later and that's when he
that's what she saw that he was smearing
syrup on his body
best was a turn-on so that [ __ ] all
right you got me
is this his house she's like my pancakes
you got me with the maple syrup why did
you have to use that so then they report
that he demanded two for her to join the
action so then they demanded so then
they started having sex and then they
ended out I mean blueberry jelly to this
condiment coitus is what they wrote
partly are they trying to cook
themselves for a giant what is going on
right now so then that's when the woman
noticed that he was reporting red okay
well this is bad okay okay changes it so
then she demanded that he delete the
footage yes but he refused all Shiva you
called the police
got it and then they thought they seized
his cell phone which had extensive video
footage of the woman they [ __ ] before
uh what makes you think that because
it's she's too comfortable well they've
been flirting because like think about
it right she goes when he right when he
put that syrup on I couldn't resist no
longer maybe there was a blueberry maple
syrup [ __ ] sandwich out of nowhere yes
I'd be disgusting the real thing is like
she saw him do that and then her
decision was to go back to work
yeah like dad was the part that I was
like oh we're calling the cops
yeah she was down from jump or just
going home just being like I'm leaving
the job this is uncomfortable ya know
she wanted but it's okay see I thought
it was it would be different if he was
like hey let's record and then
afterwards she thought about I don't
think I want to do this but the fact
that he was just kind of randomly
recording creepy that's [ __ ] up
well the widow she should be able to be
like yeah take me off this [ __ ] how was
it in his mind that he goes do you know
what's gonna get her [ __ ] syrup on my
body like how was that it worked
yeah how was that the movement of that's
when you're like loading would you just
have conversations yeah just like you
know have some banking yes all that just
kidding films sketch with honey when he
was like dropping it when he was
drooping it all over his body in slow-mo
you didn't see that
oh yeah which video is that I remember
that companies just call money yeah you
guys should watch it and then you'll
know why she got her done dude they're
all loading wood into like you know
we'll make this better some maple syrup
who don't get me more do you have weird
conversations when you work with someone
is so closely for a long time they could
have had like a sex talk they obviously
have chemistry they obviously were
flirting she said and he was like oh I
know how to get when he was loaded in
the woods - he was like like putting it
in sticking it out conversations over
she was like what a freakiest thing I
ever did was this this in this and then
he did that that's all put some like
some tarp or something I'm hoping it was
in the kitchen house oh that feels so
gross that makes sense that's all that
God though they got like even oh yeah a
lot of syrup in Connecticut you yeah but
this is a little like freaky just like
Asian TV freaky right here you know oh
yeah dude like game show [ __ ] yeah a
Japanese game shows oh yeah
so he was released after posting a
$50,000 bond what an idiot why did I
just [ __ ] delete it so that's his big
though obviously his thing is like
that's what he gets off on yeah so he
probably like how home computer he's
probably got hidden cameras at his camp
you know stuff he's obviously a charming
God yeah you know you have to be very
charming and like for to be to be able
to be naked and then a person come in
and be so comfortable that they're not
like oh my god you know I mean we're you
know that's all so he obviously has done
that before yeah in the fact that she
admitted that once he put that syrup lie
I was game you know I
when you did that video what the honey
was it hard getting it out my shower it
was gross
yeah he benighted like on his I should
open it I'm having honey all over my
body was like it was soaked in my
clothes my shirt like anything wasn't it
it was very comfortable watch for that
lady he's not licking her lips and [ __ ]
she's gonna bring honey home like
hey Nani that's just [ __ ] bee barf
honey
barf Betty puke that [ __ ] out well they
bar some good stuff yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] good no I'm just pollen right
like it's made out of pawn food you sex
you sound like a little three-year-old
asking their parents about it
mommy have you ever used sex I can't mix
it two together we try on ones with like
chocolate syrup but it was messy and as
his mom was picking him he's just like
yeah that looks like caca all over the
place just stop having sex and you end
up eating waffle him stuff right yeah
like you're painting the side of the hot
[ __ ] garage [ __ ] what are we doing
just strawberries it's like oh you know
you play with strawberry guys they're
sour look at this one here here you know
my friend yeah that's movie eyes is that
porno just like that's adult [ __ ] dude
like when you eat a fruit you don't
judge it's gonna be like dude what Mark
did you get this at doing right now
exactly you don't you're fugly loose
Adam you'll [ __ ] I mean [ __ ] you know
bring it on that plastic container
the water the waters dripping down the
thing it's like this it's like is it
ever been sexy like ever oh man [ __ ] it
sounds better
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]